Jeepers Creepers
hey everybody we are here at Gamescom
2018 and Bayview have just been sea gtfo
get with such funds out of here as my
actually called get the fun outta here
it's juicy fo yeah tell me about it I
don't know
so basically anything about it so for
player first person shooter worthy of a
light similar vanes to left the dead but
there's a much heavier emphasis on
teamwork and progression so my story is
you're these prisoners that's been taken
over by someone full of wardens and
basically you're being sent into the
core of the earth for reasons unknown I
don't know if they could just not there
they've all been there at me yeah I'm
just gonna go down at the basement and
you start with this you start on an
actual lift it just fires you like
20,000 feet into the into the ground
it's super cool but the core gameplay is
they said the heavy emphasis on teamwork
so at the start of the mission we were
told we needed to find X artifact first
obstacle there was a locked door so we
had to I had to hack into a terminal and
you have to actually type word for word
like I'm gonna hate so we found out we
needed a purple key right to go back to
the terminal type in locate purple key
then hack a bunch of stuff double back
and all the while it's yo-yo you're just
berated by these weird alien monster
things and it's not like the zombies in
the dead or aliens in the corner Duty
mode it's very tactical and like it is
very dangerous when you get into combat
these things can knock you out in in two
or three hits so it's all about team
cohesion at the start of the game you
you can see everyone's loadout so you're
like okay you take the shotgun for the
close range I'll take the machine gun
and you take the sniper rifle one guy
will take a glue gun to make traps or
reinforced walls two other people take
sentry guns and someone I like take
mines and you'll get so far into the
mission probably die because the game's
really bloody hard is it anyway okay
where do we go wrong maybe to want too
many sensor goods
we need a mapper you take a mapper then
that means you get a device that allows
you to scan through a wall or a door to
see if there's an enemy on the other
side of it extremely tactical there's a
lot to think about and it really does
take the the kind of itch that things
like left dead does yeah you can't talk
about gaming as four-player local 4
player online co-op and not talk but
I've dead but adds a lot of strategy to
it and a lot of like fear yeah well
there was like a lot of of jump scares
so wait I'm when you're going through
the game is it like a continuous
campaign or is it more like you play
like a level and then it's like
continuous runs of that CFI goes away
base so what I saw is there was a map of
levels in like the underground it starts
like the first level and if you complete
the objective you go to the next one you
get deeper and deeper and deeper and as
you get deeper the game gets harder the
levels stay the same which allows you to
learn them so the second time I did the
level with the purple key I already knew
why need to locate so without having to
find the clues I could just type it in
the game is full of clues they will just
give you one objective and how you get
there is completely up to you so you
like I said if you find a locked door
you will have to work out how it's
locked if you find one obstacle you have
to find a way around that obstacle the
game doesn't handhold you it's very much
up to you to figure out the puzzle of
the map if you die in a run like I said
it's it's that progression both in game
and personally because you're starting
to learn the map anyway but I'll always
keep you on your toes because the enemy
placement is different I don't know what
would happen when you get to the the
bottom or you do whatever the warden
wants you to do I haven't really had a
hint of that but from what I saw there
was maybe six or seven levels so far and
but no hint of the grand story or
anything like that
but to sum up you're looking forward to
it by the signs of it yeah it's like I
said like I've been looking for a game
like this for a while I was a little
apprehensive so I'm really bad with
scary games but it turns out having a
team with you and like like the emphasis
on communication is is super heavy like
even to the point where I have to be
like hey turn your flashlight off we're
about to enter a room if there's someone
the other side it's gonna give them away
really like you can't play a game
without talking yeah and for me that
that is a selling point for me because
co-op games like this if you play like a
random casual game and a co-op game
online chances are you don't get the
co-op element yeah so despite me being a
little baby child and not like in a
scary part I really like the car part so
for that bit I'm willing to give it a
shot also do we know yet when it's come
out coming out or what platforms it's
coming to I play PC not sure it's coming
out yet right it was it was very early
build on a PC of the late awesome well
for more on
gtfo get the fudge out of here and for
more from Gamescom 2018 stay tuned
games.com